et avec nous en plateau Bilal tarabé
bonjour Bilal bonjour Julien ski a
réussi à obtenir de nouvelles armes il a
fait le plein chez les Européens
absolument et en plus des livraisons
très ciblées puisque le Royaume-Uni en
gros on s'occupe de désert la France du
sol et l'Allemagne d'un petit peu tout
le reste Londres et ça a été évoqué un
plusieurs centaines de drones d'attaque
de longues portées et des missiles qui
sont du modèle Storm range qui est aussi
sont de longues portées pourquoi c'est
important cette histoire de porter parce
qu'il faut savoir que les deux donc à la
fois les drones et les missiles promis
par Londres ce sont des missiles qui
vont jusqu'à 200 250 km de de profondeur
et ça c'est ce que les Ukrainiens
réclament depuis des semaines voire des
mois c'est-à-dire la capacité de frapper
derrière les lignes des Russes et pour
l'instant les Occidentaux ne voulaient
pas parce qu'il voulait pas prendre le
risque l'un de ces missiles atterrissent
sur le territoire russe donc c'est c'est
assez c'est même très significatif comme
comme
[Musique]
en termes de de volume financiers pour
l'aide à l'Ukraine le troisième étant le
Royaume-Uni pour avoir un ordre de
comparaison en France on est presque à 2
milliards par rapport au 17 allemands
donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment pas
grand chose il faut quand même
rappeler aussi que alors certes
l'Occident est uni l'Occident aide
autant qu'il peut a priori l'Ukraine il
est uni mais il est isolé puisque il
faut quand même le dire des grands pays
de ce qu'on appelle le sud global l'Inde
l’arabie Saoudite des grands acheteurs
d'armes et bien il n'y a pas de de
d'aide à l'Ukraine autre que l'aide
occidentale en tout cas la
contre-offensive ukrainienne Bilal se
fait attendre
néanmoins ces dernières heures les
Ukrainiens ont parlé de premier victoire
en tout cas à barmut bermout qui aurait
fait l'objet d'un deal avec Wagner il y
a une information qui est sortie là du
Washington Post qui est assez étonnante
oui alors ça c'est extrêmement étonnant
c'est le mot le Washington Post révèle
pour cette information qui selon le
journal viendrait de document classifiés
du renseignement américain c'est
important qui disent en substance que
yefghani Prigogine a pris contact
plusieurs fois avec les Ukrainiens pour
leur proposer un deal que les Ukrainiens
se retirent de darkmouth donc lui laisse
à lui à Wagner la victoire et en échange
lui donnerait à l'armée ukrainienne des
renseignements sur les positions de
l'armée russe dans le dans le don-basse
alors c'est même plus précis que ça
parce que selon les renseignements
américains donc qui est venu Prigogine
aurait été en contact fin janvier avec
les Ukrainiens à la fois par téléphone
mais il aurait rencontré des membres du
renseignement militaire ukrainien en
Afrique alors
IEF gany Prigogine a réagi disons que
c'était des accusations risibles mais sa
manière de réagir à l'interpelle parce
que si vous voulez alors il dit que il
ne s'est pas rendu en Afrique que si
jamais il négocie avec les Ukrainiens ça
reviendrait à se battre avec sa main
gauche contre sa main mais à aucun
moment dans sa réaction il ne rend
hommage à l'armée russe ou bien il
réitère ça on va dire sa fidélité ou sa
bonne collaboration avec l'armée russe
10 simplement qu'il se bat au nom de la
Russie c'est une interprétation qui peut
être plus ou moins large en fonction en
fonction des analyses donc ça interpelle
quand même alors volody mirzelens qui
n'a pas confirmé des gens du
renseignement ukrainien ont confirmé ça
interpelle quand même sur le pouvoir et
les ambitions politiques de
degins si jamais c'est vrai c'est clair
on retrouvera notre correspondante à
Washington à 17h merci beaucoup Bilal